no country no continent
can defeat the coronavirus on its own we
have to join forces
and that is what the two campaigns
coronavirus global response and
global goal unite are doing
we raised almost 16 billion euros so far
and we set up a global cooperation
framework
the act accelerator together with our
international partners in particular
the world health organization
this act accelerator will enable us
to develop and deploy vaccines
tests and treatments to all who need it
in the world
and today we go one step further
the european commission is ready to join
the kovacs facility
this covax facility is being designed
to organize the procurement of vaccines
against coronavirus at global level
we will join kovacs together with our eu
member states
as team europe and the commission will
also make a contribution of 400 million
euro in
guarantees to the kovacs facility
and its goals this contribution
will help buy and deliver doses of
future vaccines
for low and middle-income countries
in parallel we continue negotiating with
pharmaceutical companies
to purchase doses of vaccines on behalf
of the eu member states
because one thing is clear we will not
be
safe until everyone whether here in
europe
or out there in the world is safe
we need global solidarity the european
commission's
contribution to covax brings us one step
closer to this goal